Le chapitre 12
Les hérodiens
Les sadocéens
Les leaderships d'Israël
Mais ce qui est clair
C'est que par chaque attaque
Jésus donne une réponse absolue
Il n'est pas mouable
Il est là
En train de prévaloir
Contre toutes les réponses
Contre toutes les questions
Avec des réponses magistrales
Mais quelque chose de différent
Se passe à ce moment
Jusqu'ici
On a vu
Les sénédrins
Qui venaient mettre en question
L'autorité du Christ
On a vu les pharisiens
Qui voulaient mettre en question
La question des tribus
Devant les hérodiens
On a vu
La question de la ressurrection
Vis-à-vis aux sadocéens
Donc
Tous les types de polémiques
Des discussions théologiques
Ils ont voulu
Attraper Jésus
Avec une mauvaise intention
A partir de ces moments
On va trouver un homme
Qui fait partie des escribes
Des spécialistes de la loi
Ceux qui étaient responsables
D'étudier
De mémoriser
La parole de Dieu
De transcrire
Leur boulot était vraiment
D'étudier l'Ancien Testament
Complètement
Et cet homme là
Il
Vient avec une approche
Assez intéressant
Il
Qui semble être
Un peu plus développée
Que l'approche des autres
Il ne semble pas être
Tout à fait
Dans l'intention
De chasser Jésus
Mais plutôt
Il démontre avoir
Une espèce d'admiration
Et
Le plus intéressant
A mon avis
C'est qu'on voit
Une espèce de développement
Des sujets
Il est
Il